There's a guy I see every time I go to work. He sits on the sidewalk right next to the newsstand, always in that same spot. His hair is dreadlocked and dirty, and he's often quietly muttering to himself. A few decades ago, if you would have asked a bunch of experts what they think this person needs, like what is the best way to help him, the answers you would have gotten would be really different than the ones you'd get now. And that shift in thinking,
每次我去上班，都会看到一个人。他坐在报摊旁边的马路牙子上，总是待在同一个地方。他留着脏兮兮的脏辫，经常一个人轻声咕哝着。几十年前，如果你去问一堆专家，他们觉得这个人需要什么，或者说帮助他的最好方法是什么，你得到的答案和现在会有很大的不同。这种思维方式的转变，
it's at least partly because of this guy. All right, hey, Katie. Carlos here, she's got the microphone. That's Sam Semberis, with producer Carla Green, who we sent to record him. Okay, yeah, just tell me what you have for breakfast this morning. Tell you what? What you had for breakfast?
至少在某种程度上是因为这个家伙。好了，嘿，凯蒂。这是卡洛斯，她拿着话筒。那是山姆·森贝里斯，还有我们派去录音的制作人卡拉·格林。好吧，没错，告诉我你今天早上吃了什么早餐。你说什么？你吃了什么早餐？
What I had for breakfast this morning. So I've been eating bagels for breakfast for the last three days. Okay, I think I know that. So did I pass? I mean, is that okay? What if it was scrambled eggs? It's like, no, is there a right answer? I just had a right answer. I just had an equation that...
我今天早上吃了什么早餐。我过去三天早餐都吃的是百吉饼。好吧，我想我知道这个。那我通过了吗？我是说，这样可以吗？如果我吃的是炒鸡蛋呢？就像，不，有没有正确答案？我刚刚才有一个正确答案。我刚才有一个方程……
Sam is a psychologist who back in the 1980s was working with homeless people in New York City. And the ideas that came out of the work he was doing are pretty foundational to how people think about solving homelessness today. Back then, Sam's typical day was spent driving around the streets of New York in a van with a nurse and a psychiatrist essentially making sidewalk house calls to the city's homeless.
山姆是一位心理学家，在 20 世纪 80 年代，他在纽约市从事无家可归者的工作。他当时的工作所产生的理念，对于今天人们如何看待解决无家可归问题起到了非常基础的作用。在那时，山姆典型的一天是和一名护士以及一名精神科医生一起，开着一辆面包车在纽约的街道上四处转悠，本质上是为全市的无家可归者提供路边上门服务。
Two or three of us would be in the van with a driver, and we would receive referrals, all kinds of people would call and say, I have to, I want to refer somebody to you. I saw them on the corner of 65th and Park. They're ranting and they don't look well at all. And they're standing out in the middle of the traffic, trying to convert the drivers into some belief system. The 1980s was really the beginning of homelessness as we now know it, mainly because of rising income inequality
我们车上有两三个人加上司机，我们会接到转介，各种各样的人会打电话说，我必须、我想向你们转介一个人。我在65街和公园大道的转角看到了他们。他们在长篇大论，看起来状态非常糟糕。他们站在车流中间，试图把司机们转化到某种信仰体系中。20世纪80年代确实是我们现在所知的无家可归现象的开端，主要是由于收入不平等加剧，
and the dismantling of a lot of social programs like public housing. The crack up a Demick and deinstitutionalization certainly didn't help matters either. Anyway, homelessness was particularly exploding in New York, and there was a feeling that some of the people on the streets might be a danger to themselves or to others. And if they met that criteria, we would bring them to the hospital voluntarily if we could accomplish that, persuade them to go or involuntarily if necessary, we would call the police and they would be taken sometimes in handcuffs to the Bellevue psychiatric emergency room. Sam thought there were times when, in voluntary commitment,
以及公共住房等许多社会福利项目的拆解。快克毒品风暴和去机构化当然也无济于事。无论如何，纽约的无家可归现象尤为爆发，人们有一种感觉，街上的一些人可能会对自己或他人构成危险。如果他们符合这一标准，只要能做到，我们会自愿将他们送往医院，说服他们去；如果必要的话，我们也会非自愿地把他们送去，我们会报警，有时他们会被戴上手铐带到贝尔维尤精神科急诊室。山姆认为有时非自愿收治是
it was necessary, but he was never completely comfortable with it. Sam had ended up in New York City for grad school, where he got interested in the psychiatric survivors movement. The movement challenged the traditional paternalism of psychiatry and promoted the idea that patients should control their own care. This was the future Sam wanted, which put him at odds sometimes with his co-workers. We ended up in Grand Central Station one night. The team was responding to a call about a homeless person that they referred to as the cat
必要的，但他对此从未完全感到自在。山姆最终来到纽约市读研究生，在那里他对精神病幸存者运动产生了兴趣。这场运动挑战了精神病学的传统家长式作风，并提倡患者应该控制自己的护理的理念。这是山姆想要的未来，这有时使他与同事产生矛盾。一天晚上，我们最终来到了中央车站。团队正在处理一个关于一个无家可归者的求助电话，他们把这个人称作猫
woman. Because she loved cats and when she was outside she'd have a cat sometimes with her. She always wore black, completely black outfits. And she was in the bathroom, the women's bathroom of a grand central station where she would stay. And she was like, leave me alone. I hate you people. They thought, oh, she's in denial of her desperate situation, she's not safe. So they bring her to the hospital. I was very upset by that.
女士。因为她喜欢猫，当她在外面时，有时会随身带一只猫。她总是穿黑色，全黑的衣服。她待在中央车站的女洗手间里，那是她落脚的地方。她当时就像是在说，离我远点。我讨厌你们这些人。他们觉得，哦，她对自己的绝望处境处于否认状态，她不安全。于是他们把她带到了医院。对此我感到非常不安。
This was not a situation Sam thought called for involuntary commitment. And so he made an anonymous call to the legal aid program in the hospital. I said, I don't want to say who I am, I just want to tell you about a situation that's in the hospital right now. There's this woman that was hospitalized involuntarily. I think she needs representation. She wants to be out of the hospital. This was an early sign that Sam was generally on team patient over a team psychiatrist. Still, he worked like this for a couple more years, driving around the city,
这不是山姆认为需要进行非自愿收治的情况。于是他匿名拨打了医院法律援助项目的电话。我说，我不想透露我是谁，我只是想告诉你现在医院里发生的一个情况。这里有一个被非自愿住院的女人。我认为她需要辩护。她想离开医院。这是山姆总体上倾向于“患者战队”而不是“精神科医生战队”的一个早期迹象。尽管如此，他还是这样工作了几年，在城市里开车转悠，
checking in on people, sometimes taking people to Bellevue. We took about 300 people a year to Bellevue, like one a day, you know, on average. And at the end of the year, when I was doing follow-up studies, like what happened to these people, many of them, like two thirds, would simply be returning to the streets. And so there was like an awareness that whatever this is, whatever we're trying to do with this population is not working, it's not working. This is according to need, chapter three. to need chapter three.
探望人们，有时把人带到贝尔维尤。我们每年大约带300人去贝尔维尤，平均每天一个左右，你知道的。到了年底，当我做追踪研究时，比如这些人后来怎么样了，他们中的许多人，比如三分之二，会简单地重返街头。因此人们有一种意识，即无论这是什么，无论我们试图对这个群体做什么，都是行不通的，行不通的。这是根据需求，第三章。
After a couple years of this routine, taking people to Bellevue, seeing them bounce back onto the streets, Sam decided to try something new. Instead of dragging people off to the hospital, or kind of, here's your diagnosis, and here's your prescription methodology, Sam wanted to try basically just asking people how he could help. We're gonna listen to our clients, and we're gonna really offer them the things they want
经过几年的这种日常——把人带到贝尔维尤，看着他们重返街头——山姆决定尝试点新东西。山姆没有把人们强行拖到医院，或者采用那种“这是你的诊断，这是你的处方”的方法，而是想尝试基本上只问问人们他能如何提供帮助。我们要倾听客户的心声，我们要真正向他们提供他们想要的东西，
in the sequence they wanted. We were gonna facilitate it. Sam hired a new team, some of whom had personal lived experience with homelessness, and they opened a drop-in center for people who were struggling with either mental illness or addiction or both. They named the center choices unlimited, although mostly people just called it choices. Choices wanted to give people a place to come and rest, take a shower, and then start to think about a plan. Like we're still homeless, but we could go there during the day and get shower and change
按照他们想要的顺序。我们将为此提供便利。山姆雇佣了一个新团队，其中一些人有无家可归的个人生活经验，他们为那些与精神疾病、毒瘾或两者兼而有之作斗争的人开办了一个日间收容中心。他们将这个中心命名为“无限选择”，尽管人们通常只叫它“选择”。“选择”希望给人们提供一个可以来休息、洗个澡，然后开始考虑计划的地方。就像我们仍然无家可归，但我们可以在白天去那里洗个澡、换
clothes and they buy a lunch. This is Alan. I'm just going to use his first name to protect his privacy. Alan was one of the first clients at Choices. He'd grown up in Boston and had made his way to New York in the early 80s. By the time he ended up at the Choices drop-in center, he'd already had a bunch of interactions with the kind of psychiatry that Sam was hoping to move away from. When Alan was just 13, he ended up in Bridgewater State Hospital after getting into a fight. Bridgewater was an infamous prison slash hospital for the so-called criminally insane. Prison slash hospital was a prison period.
衣服，然后他们买一份午餐。这是艾伦。为了保护他的隐私，我只用他的名。艾伦是“选择”的第一批客户之一。他在波士顿长大，8年代初来到了纽约。等他来到“选择”日间收容中心时，他已经和山姆想要摆脱的那类精神病学有过多次接触了。艾伦13岁时，在打了一架后被送进了布里奇沃特州立医院。布里奇沃特是一所臭名昭著的监狱兼医院，专门关押所谓的精神失常罪犯。监狱兼医院，其实就是个监狱。
They just called it a hospital. That was a torture chamber. That's what it was. I turned 14 and wanted to sell. Alan told me that abuse from his mother and mistreatment from all kinds of authority figures had left him full of rage that he couldn't always control. I got to a point where I wasn't taking no shit from nobody.
他们只是管它叫医院。那是个刑讯室。事实就是这样。我14岁时就想卖东西。艾伦告诉我，母亲的虐待和各种权威人士的虐待让他充满了他无法总是控制的愤怒。我到了那种谁的屁话也不听的地步。
Oh yeah, I used to fight a lot. I do got a short temper when it comes to a bunch of bull crap. He would come into my office like, you're the dogs, if they ever do this to me, I'm gonna kill them, you know, like this. And I'm like, Alan, you can't actually say these things. It's a mental health program. Like, people are gonna come and lock you up,
哦，是的，我以前经常打架。遇到一堆废话的时候，我的脾气确实很急。他会走进我的办公室说，你们这群混蛋，如果他们敢这么对我的话，我要宰了他们，你知道的，就像这样。我说，艾伦，你不能真的说这些话。这是一个心理健康项目。听着，人们会来把你关起来，
you know, like, you gotta watch your language, you know. For Alan, it was anger, but all the clients at choices were dealing with some kind of mental health issue. Things like bipolar disorder and schizophrenia. These clients didn't trust the choices other people made for them, but maybe they would trust their own. Sam's job was just to help make it happen. You want a drug rehab program? We'll help you find one and enroll. You want to get on meds? We'll get you connected to the right doctors.
你知道的，所以你得注意你的言辞，你知道的。对艾伦来说，那是愤怒，但“选择”的所有客户都在处理某种心理健康问题。比如双相情感障碍和精神分裂症。这些客户不信任别人为他们做出的选择，但也许他们会信任他们自己的。山姆的工作就是帮助实现这一点。你想要一个戒毒项目？我们会帮你找一个并协助你注册。你想吃药？我们会帮你联系合适的医生。
You want housing? Cool. We can help with that too. Except housing, it turned out, was tricky. It was also what Alan and just about everyone else wanted. So, okay, people want housing. So there were any number of housing providers open for business at that time. The system for getting into housing at that time in the 1980s and 90s was designed as a sort of staircase.
你想要住房？酷。我们也能帮到忙。除了住房，事实证明，这很棘手。这也是艾伦和几乎其他所有人想要的。所以，好吧，人们想要住房。因此，当时有任意数量的住房提供商在营业。在80和90年代，进入住房系统的过程被设计成了一种类似阶梯的结构。
You started at the bottom in shelter and then if you fulfilled certain requirements like getting sober or taking your meds, you graduated to something sort of like a dormitory. From there, you might go to a shared apartment with a few other people. The final, final step at the very top of the staircase might be your own apartment in a building with other formerly homeless people, but it was hard to get there. The idea behind the staircase was something people called housing readiness. A kind of a quarantining to get people ready for housing and get them to get their life together so that they can get back into housing.
你从底层的收容所开始，然后如果你满足了某些要求，比如戒酒或按时服药，你就可以晋级到有点像宿舍的地方。从那里开始，你可能会去和其他几个人合租一套公寓。阶梯最顶端的最后一步，可能是你在一个住着其他曾经无家可归之人的大楼里拥有自己的公寓，但要到达那一步很难。阶梯背后的理念是人们所称的“住房准备度”。这是一种隔离期，为了让人们为住房做好准备，让他们把生活整顿好，以便能够重新回到住房中。
To say, the staircase felt frustratingly paternalistic. When he heard housing readiness, it sounded more like housing worthiness. You know, the kind of improve the poor attitude. The staff at choices helped the clients apply for these programs. But inevitably, the housing providers would end up asking things like,
对于山姆来说，这个阶梯让人感到沮丧地带有家长式作风。当他听到“住房准备度”时，听起来更像是“住房资格”。你知道的，那种“改善穷人”的态度。“选择”的工作人员帮助客户申请这些项目。但不可避免地，住房提供商最终会问一些问题，比如：
how long have you been clean and sober? And if you have a mental illness, what sort of treatment are you doing? What medications are you taking, etc. And so when these kinds of questions came up, our applicants repeatedly failed the housing interviews. We could not persuade housing providers to take anybody. We were failing miserably. It's sort of a problem when you start a program called choices unlimited,
你保持清醒戒毒多久了？如果你有精神疾病，你正在接受什么样的治疗？你在服用什么药物，等等。因此，当出现这类问题时，我们的申请者在住房面试中屡屡失败。我们无法说服住房提供商接受任何人。我们失败得惨不忍睹。当你创办了一个名为“无限选择”的项目，
only to find that the choices are, in fact, quite limited. And so once again, Sam started thinking about doing something new. Something that at the time barely anyone had actually tried before. He wanted to try moving homeless people with significant mental health issues straight from the streets into their own apartments, just regular apartments that they would find for folks on the private market.
结果却发现选择实际上非常有限时，这就成了一个问题。于是，山姆再次开始考虑做一些新事情。在当时，几乎没有人真正尝试过的事情。他想尝试把有严重心理健康问题的无家可归者直接从街上送进他们自己的公寓，也就是他们在私营市场上为人们找到的普通公寓。
This approach would come to be known as housing first, but back then it was just a wild idea they were trying out. You know, the people we were going to house, when you met them, they didn't inspire confidence that it would all work out okay. Sam and his colleagues secured money from the state office of mental health services to pay for this experiment.
这种方法后来被称为“住房优先”，但在当时这只是他们正在尝试的一个疯狂想法。你知道的，我们要安置的人，当你见到他们时，他们并不能激起人们对一切都会顺利解决的信心。山姆和他的同事们从州心理健康服务办公室获得了资金来支付这项实验。
Enough for 50 apartments plus case management services. And they started a new nonprofit to handle all this new work called Pathways to Housing. One of the first things they had to do was reach out to landlords. So you have to beat the streets and find the people that are willing to work with you. And what would you tell them about the clients?
这笔资金足够支付50套公寓加上个案管理服务的费用。他们成立了一个新的非营利组织来处理所有这些新工作，名为“通往住房之路”。他们必须做的第一件事就是联系房东。所以你必须走访大街小巷，找到愿意与你合作的人。你会对他们说些什么关于客户的事？
We would tell them as little as possible. Sam said they would tell people basically we're working with low-income clients helping them find housing but not we're working with formerly homeless severely mentally ill clients who are also struggling with addiction. They also had people on staff whose specific job it was to communicate with landlords and it helped Sam said that they were always able to guarantee the rent would be paid. Pathways clients would have to put 30% of their incomes toward rent, but the rest would be covered.
我们会尽可能少地透露。山姆说，他们基本上会告诉人们，我们正在与低收入客户合作，帮助他们找到住房，但不会说我们正在与曾经无家可归、患有严重精神疾病且还在与毒瘾作斗争的客户合作。他们的员工中也有专门负责与房东沟通的人，山姆说，这很有帮助，因为他们总是能够保证房租按时支付。“通往住房之路”的客户必须将他们收入的30%用于支付房租，其余部分则由机构覆盖。
For most clients, the 30% came out of some kind of benefit check they were eligible to receive from the government. The hope was that pathways would continue to provide this subsidy for the rest of these clients' lives, if they needed it. Although at the beginning Sam said no one had any idea whether this experiment would last. Sam told us that the apartment says I was as soon as we get the leases. So we were sitting down there in choices one day and this young lady she was the
对于大多数客户来说，这30%来自他们有资格从政府领取的某种福利支票。人们希望，如果客户需要的话，“通往住房之路”将在这些客户的余生中继续提供这种补贴。尽管在开始时，山姆说没有人知道这个实验是否能持久。山姆告诉我们，公寓一拿到租约就……所以有一天我们坐在“选择”里，那位年轻女士，她是……
There's receptionist on a secretary or whatever And she got all the sweaty guys standing around her, you know at that factory see that we're watching this Fax machine for St. Lisa's out and we're standing there. Oh, there's my right there my He's coming out over there. That's my boy, you know Soon as we got the least we walk walked over to that apartment building to Alex. He was the super. And we show him that lease and he knows everything's legitimate. Then he give us the keys and point to the apartment that she owes.
前台接待员还是秘书什么的，周围围着一群满头大汗的家伙，你知道的，在那个工厂里，看我们在盯着传真机，看圣丽莎的租约发出来没有，我们站在那儿。哦，我的在那儿，就在那儿！他从那边出来了。那是我的好兄弟，你知道的。一拿到租约，我们就走到那栋公寓楼去找阿莱克斯。他是管理员。我们把租约给他看，他知道一切都是合法的。然后他把钥匙给我们，指着那套属于她的公寓。
I was so overwhelmed with joy. I didn't know how to act. This is Camaradine Smallwood. Indeed would be my middle initial. Smallwood is my last name. But I prefer to be called Kamar because that's my Muslim name, so that's who I am, so I love that name. Like Alan, Kamar was one of the first people to get housing through the Pathways program. For the last several years, she'd been sleeping wherever she could. I slept all over the place.
我当时喜极而泣。我都不知道该怎么表现了。这是卡马拉丁·斯莫尔3世。中间名首字母确实是迪。斯莫尔伍德是我的姓。但我更喜欢别人叫我卡马尔，因为那是我的穆斯林名字，那才是我本人，所以我很喜欢这个名字。和艾伦一样，卡马尔是通过“住房优先”项目获得住房的第一批人之一。在过去的几年里，她一直在能找到的任何地方睡觉。我到处睡觉。
I slept in the subway station in 42nd Street. Before you get to the end train, it used to be a new stand in the bathroom. And there was a lady that worked and cleaned the bathroom. And at night time, she would lock me in the bathroom so I would stand in and I would go to sleep. And then when she came in the morning to clean up, she opened it during, let me out.
我睡在42nd街的地铁站里。在到达终点列车之前，那里以前有一个报摊和洗手间。有一个女工负责打扫洗手间。到了晚上，她会把我锁在洗手间里，这样我就可以待在里面睡觉。然后当她早上来打扫时，她把它打开，把我放出去。
I slept in a cardboard box under the FDR drive. I think that was. Finally, after years of homelessness, Kamara and her boyfriend, who was also homeless, were getting their own place. We had park a floors, central heating, central air conditioning. We had park a floors, central heating, central air conditioning. We had two bedrooms and it was only me and him.
我睡在FDR快速路下的纸箱里。我想是的。最后，经过多年的无家可归生活，卡马尔和她同样无家可归的男友有了自己的住处。我们有镶木地板，中央暖气，中央空调。我们有镶木地板，中央暖气，中央空调。我们有两个卧室，而且只有我和他两个人。
If you wanted to go to the park, just cross the street, go over there and have a cook out. We had a night, we live right on a central park west 100th, 10th street. Beautiful. Nice over there. Do you remember like trying to kind of set it up and decorate it and just feeling like? I wasn't even thinking about decoration. I was just so glad I wasn't in the street. But that beautiful place by the park. It didn't last that long.
如果你想去公园，过马路去那边野餐就行了。我们有一个晚上，我们就住在中央公园西路110街。太美了。那边环境很好。你还记得当时试图布置和装饰它，然后感觉……吗？我当时根本没想过装饰。我只是太高兴我不在街上了。但是公园旁边的那个美丽地方并没有持续多久。
We was living there and we was doing well, but we just couldn't let go of any drugs. Yeah, we was running out, going around and going to buy drugs and coming back. I don't know if anybody's seen us go buy drugs and then come back because all I know is that they kept saying we were doing a lot of running out and they're not having it. A few months into their stay, Kamar and her partner got kicked out of their building. I felt really bad. I felt like that. I wish I could get off these drugs. Allen had problems too. Not with his apartment.
我们在那里住得很好，但我们就是戒不掉毒品。是的，我们会跑出去，四处去买毒品然后再回来。我不知道有没有人看到我们去买毒品然后回来，因为我只知道他们一直说我们经常跑出去，他们无法容忍这一点。住了几个月后，卡马尔和她的伴侣被赶出了他们的公寓。我感觉真的很糟糕。我觉得……我真希望自己能戒掉毒品。艾伦也有问题。不是他的公寓有问题。
Allen's problem was always his anger. He got in fights with everyone, with coworkers, police, case workers. It didn't take much, you know, like for him to get very upset. He had a very low threshold for disappointment. And he would threaten people, like, and he was very, very good at threats. I mean, they were not like, I'll kill you. Like, they were very specific to the person, you know, like he knew how to read
艾伦的问题一直是他的脾气。他跟所有人都打架，跟同事、警察、个案工作者。不需要花太多力气，你知道的，他就会非常生气。他对失望的容忍度极低。他会威胁别人，而且他非常、非常擅长发出威胁。我的意思是，他们说的不是“我要杀了你”。他们的威胁对特定的人非常具体，你知道的，他知道如何解读
people's vulnerabilities in a way. It was kind of uncanny. At some point, Alan had threatened so many people at Pathways that the program director told Sam, he'd get kicked out if he did it one more time. Sam's experiment was being tested. You know, it's not like this thing solves your problems of loneliness, of poverty, of addiction, of mental illness, of disconnection from your family.
人们的脆弱之处，某种程度上真是不可思议。在某个时候，艾伦威胁了太多“通往住房之路”的工作人员，以至于项目主管告诉山姆，如果他再来一次，就会被踢出去。山姆的实验正在受到考验。你知道的，这东西并不能解决你孤独、贫穷、毒瘾、精神疾病、与家人疏离的问题。
It's not like a panacea. The whole point of doing housing first is you can actually start to deal with these other things, which are much more profound and much more difficult. At least it gives you a shot at having those conversations, because if people are on the street, you're never going to be able to have those conversations, because it's all about, where am I going to sleep, and what am I going to eat, and, you know, like I'm safe. Sam is fond of saying housing first does not mean housing only, and pathways clients
它不是什么灵丹妙药。实行“住房优先”的全部意义在于，你终于可以开始处理这些更深层次、更困难的问题了。至少它让你有机会进行这些对话，因为如果人们露宿街头，你永远无法进行这些对话，因为一切都围绕着：我今晚去哪儿睡，我吃什么，以及，你知道的，我安全吗。山姆喜欢说“住房优先”并不意味着“仅有住房”，“通往住房之路”的客户
had access to all kinds of support, like therapy and drug treatment. And in general, Sam just tried really hard not to give up on folks. When Alan was on the verge of getting kicked out of the program for threatening people, Sam took him out to dinner to make one last appeal. And we were at a Chinese restaurant and I had to kind of convey this news to him that if he threatened anyone else on the staff that that would be it we couldn't work with him anymore. And when I started telling him about it, I started to cry because I because I'd spent years just like trying to hold on to people and here I'm telling him like I have to go. And when he saw me crying, his response was, I had no idea it meant that much to you.
可以获得各种支持，比如治疗和戒毒。总的来说，山姆只是非常努力地不放弃任何人。当艾伦因为威胁他人而濒临被项目开除时，山姆带他去吃晚饭，做最后的争取。我们在一家中餐馆，我不得不把这个消息传达给他：如果他再威胁任何工作人员，那就是最后通牒了，我们不能再和他合作了。当我开始跟他说起这个时，我开始哭泣，因为我花了几年时间试图不放弃人们，而现在我却在告诉他，我不得不让他走。当他看到我哭时，他的反应是，我不知道这对你意味着这么多。
I'm not going to do that anymore. He did it. Look, I saw it in his face. That's what made me that I'll tell you the truth. That's what really made me really stop, stop, stop, because I did see that. You know, this guy really trying to protect me because he didn't have to do that. That's what I told myself.
我再也不那样做了。他确实做到了。听着，我在他脸上看出来了。这就是让我……我跟你说实话。这才是真正让我彻底停下来的原因，因为我确实看到了。你知道的，这家伙真的在努力保护我，因为他根本没必要这么做。我当时这么对自己说。
And that's when I started chilling out a bit. As for Camor, Pathway's encouraged her to go to rehab before she tried again with housing, which I have to say I found sort of surprising at first. I thought it was always housing first, then treatment. But when I asked Sam about it, he said no, not necessarily. The goal was always for their clients to get better, healthier. They never would have made housing contingent on rehab, but that doesn't mean they wouldn't have encouraged someone to try it before moving
也就是从那时起，我开始冷静下来一点。至于卡马尔，“通往住房之路”鼓励她在再次尝试住房之前去戒毒所，说实话，我一开始觉得这挺意外的。我以为总是先有住房，然后才有治疗。但当我问山姆时，他说不，不一定。他们的目标始终是让客户变得更好、更健康。他们绝不会把住房作为戒毒的附加条件，但这并不意味着他们不会鼓励某人在搬回
back into an apartment. When Kamar got out of the program, Pathways helped her get a second place. This time she decorated. Putting hanging things on the wall. I painted my bedroom. Yeah. That first year Sam told me he thinks probably 20% of the clients bounced out of their place at least once and had to be rehoused. That was just the cost of doing business. But even though people had plenty of challenges to address, Sam increasingly believed that there were very few people who weren't ready for housing.
公寓之前尝试一下。当卡马尔完成项目后，“通往住房之路”帮她找了第二处住所。这一次她进行了装饰。在墙上挂东西。我粉刷了我的卧室。是的。山姆告诉我，第一年他认为大约有20%的客户至少有一次被赶出住所，不得不重新被安置。这只是开展业务的成本。但尽管人们有大量需要解决的挑战，山姆越来越坚信，几乎没有什么人是没有准备好入住住房的。
That included people yelling on the corner, people who smell so bad on the train that everyone moves away. And yeah, the guy I see every day by the new stand on my way to work. Here's the criteria. No matter what the person looks like, if you see they're able to survive on the street
这包括在街角大喊大叫的人，在地铁里味道难闻到让所有人都躲开的人。是的，还有我每天上班路上在报摊旁看到的那个人。标准是这样的。不管这个人看起来怎么样，如果你看到他们能够在街头生存下来，
by virtue of their survival on the street on in that tent or in that park and as smelly and as awful as they look if they're surviving on the street they can definitely survive in an apartment. Yeah because like I see the same people every day when I go to work and they're sitting in the same spot. And so in my mind they exist. Yes, yes, yes, yes. But of course they don't. Of course.
凭借他们在这个帐篷里或这个公园里的街头生存能力，不管他们闻起来多臭、看起来多可怕，只要他们在街上能活下来，他们绝对能在公寓里活下来。对啊，因为我每天上班时都看到同样的人坐在同一个地方。所以在我的脑海里，他们是存在的。是的，是的，是的，是的。但当然他们不是。当然不是。
They have to eat. They have to go to the bathroom. They have to be safe. They have probably a monthly benefit check that they're getting in some church post off his box who knows what. Sam does concede that there are some people who may need more of an institutional setting, but they're often the same people who haven't been able to take care of their own basic needs while living on the street.
他们得吃东西。他们得上厕所。他们必须保证安全。他们可能有一张每月发放的福利支票，存在某个教堂的邮政信箱里，谁知道呢。山姆确实承认，有些人可能更需要机构化的环境，但他们往往也是那些在街头生活时无法照顾自己基本需求的人。
Every year pathways took on more clients who were given permanent subsidized housing and supportive services, and they started making presentations to their colleagues at conferences. Like look, this whole concept of housing readiness, that people need to be sober or mentally fit before being housed. It's not necessary. Everyone is ready. But a lot of people just couldn't believe it. In fact, some people thought it was unethical to the clients themselves. Like giving them their own place was setting them up to fail. So we had to do a randomized control trial. This time they ran the study as a real clinical trial with a control group and a treatment group.
每年，“通往住房之路”都会接纳更多客户，为他们提供永久性补贴住房和支持性服务，他们开始在会议上向同行进行展示。就像是看吧，“住房准备度”这个概念——即人们在获得住房之前必须保持清醒或精神健康——是不必要的。每个人都准备好了。但许多人根本不相信。事实上，有些人认为这对客户本身是不道德的。就像给他们自己的住所是注定让他们失败一样。所以我们不得不做一个随机对照试验。这一次，他们将这项研究作为真正的临床试验来运行，设有对照组和治疗组。
They enrolled 225 people, all who had a psychiatric diagnosis of severe mental illness. And although it wasn't a requirement, most of the participants also had a history of abusing drugs or alcohol. And then we just coined toss, housing first, treatment is usual. Treatment is usual was a staircase approach I talked about earlier, in which you have to be housing ready, i.e. sober, to start the program. And if you relapse at any point, you were out. The data took a few years to gather because the whole point was watching people over time.
他们招募了225人，所有人都被诊断出患有严重的精神疾病。虽然这不是硬性要求，但大多数参与者也有滥用毒品或酒精的历史。然后我们只是抛硬币，住房优先，常规治疗。常规治疗就是我前面提到的阶梯式方法，你必须具备住房准备度，即保持清醒，才能开始项目。如果在任何时候复吸，你就出局了。数据花了几年的时间才收集完，因为全部的意义在于随着时间的推移观察人们。
It was finally published in 2004, and the results were pretty astonishing. And the treatment as usual group, only 34% of the people in the study still had housing after two years. But in the pathways group, 80% did. Sam's favorite graph to come out of the study still had housing after two years. But in the Pathways Group, 80% did. Sam's favorite graph to come out of the study, the one he actually taped to his door, was the one that showed how much time over the course of the study, each group had spent being
这项研究最终于2004年发表，结果相当惊人。在常规治疗组中，研究中只有34%的人在两年后仍然拥有住房。但在“住房优先”组中，这一比例达到了80%。山姆最喜欢的从研究中得出的图表——在两年后仍拥有住房的图表。但在“住房优先”组中，这一比例达到了80%。山姆最喜欢的从研究中得出的图表，也就是他实际上贴在门上的那张，显示了在研究过程中，每个组处于无家可归状态的时间。
homeless. Days homeless for the control group, you know, was a slope down and they had reduced it by about 40 percent. And days homeless on housing first went all the way down to like 3 percent. Like right along the baseline, like a snake, it was beautiful. It was beautiful. But even after the results were published, there were still doubters. People thought New York is very, very well subsidized in
对照组无家可归的天数，你知道的，是一条向下的斜线，他们将其减少了大约40%。而“住房优先”组无家可归的天数一路下降到了大约3%。就像沿着基准线一样，像一条蛇，太美了。太美了。但即使在结果发表之后，仍然有怀疑论者。人们认为纽约的补贴非常非常充足，
And no other place could do what you do in New York. The water comes from the Hudson. Everyone's drinking the same water. It could be that. It could be anything. It could be the bagels. Yeah, it could be the same water, could be that. Could be anything. It could be the bagels. Yeah, could be the bagels.
其他任何地方都无法做到你在纽约做的事。水来自哈德逊河。每个人喝的水都一样。可能是这个原因。可能是什么原因都行。可能是百吉饼的原因。对，可能是相同的水，可能是那个原因。可能是什么原因都行。可能是百吉饼的原因。对，可能是百吉饼。
Exactly. There was also a theory that maybe it only worked because of Sam's singular dedication to the work. And this theory, I have to admit, seemed kind of legit to me. I mean, Komara talks about Sam as if he's only a smidge below a law. No, really. I give all glory to a law and then when I step down from that, I give Sam his props. I never heard any clients complain about Sam. We always talk about, well, Sam got a plan.
确实如此。还有一种理论认为，这可能只归功于山姆对这项工作无可替代的奉献精神。我必须承认，这个理论对我来说似乎挺合理的。我的意思是，卡马尔谈论山姆时的神情，就好像他只比真主低一点点。不，真的。我把所有的荣耀归于真主，然后在这个基础之下，我给山姆应得的赞誉。我从没听过任何客户抱怨山姆。我们总是在讨论，嗯，山姆有个计划。
What we gonna do? Yeah, Sam got a plan. The only thing I heard was I asked my coworkers now, and I said, you know Sam, and they were like, oh, I know I heard about him, but I never met him. I said, wow, you shouldn't met Sam. Well, that's not anything bad. No, that's not anything bad.
我们该怎么办？是的，山姆有个计划。我听到的唯一的抱怨是，我现在问我的同事，我说，你知道山姆吗？他们会说，哦，我知道，我听说过他，但我没见过他。我说，哇，你真应该见见山姆。好吧，这倒没什么不好的。不，这真没什么不好的。
But if you wanna talk about what's the worst thing, that's the worst, because I'm like, if you don't know Sam, you don't know what you're missing. So basically, the worst thing about Sam is the idea of not having a Sam. And when Sam backed up from the day-to-day operations at Pathways, New York, to bring the housing first model to other places. Allen and Kumar both said things didn't run as smoothly. Matter of fact, I really didn't care for Pathways as much once Sam wasn't like, you know, when he was doing bigger things. But Sam gets kind of sassy if you suggest the Pathways model can't be replicated without him. Well, obviously not. Right?
但如果你要谈论最糟糕的是什么，那就是这个，因为我觉得如果你不认识山姆，你就不知道自己错过了什么。所以基本上，关于山姆最糟糕的事情就是没有山姆。当山姆从纽约“通往住房之路”的日常运营中退居二线，去把“住房优先”模式带到其他地方时。艾伦和卡马尔都说事情没有以前那么顺利了。事实上，一旦山姆不在像以前那样——你知道的，当他去做更大事情的时候——我其实就没那么喜欢“通往住房之路”了。但如果你暗示没有他，“住房优先”模式就无法复制，山姆就会有点生气。好吧，显然不是这样，对吧？
I mean, the program is all over the world, so it's not so that hard to replicate after all. Sass, notwithstanding, Sam is right. Since he first ran that program in New York, the model has spread far and wide. Sam had proved housing first could work. But what really helped the model spread was some convincing research by a guy named Dennis Colhane. Dennis Colhane had identified that for the population that we were housing, the housing first population that most vulnerable, was costing taxpayers a fortune. What Sam means is it was costing taxpayers a fortune to allow these folks to stay homeless. The people that Sam had been working with, who were often talked about as the most vulnerable, because they were dealing with a lot of extra challenges, like mental illness, addiction,
我的意思是，这个项目遍布全球，所以毕竟也没那么难复制。傲娇归傲娇，山姆是对的。自从他在纽约首次运行该项目以来，这种模式已经传播得非常广泛。山姆证明了“住房优先”是行之有效的。但真正帮助该模式传播的是一个名叫丹尼斯·柯尔哈恩的人所做的令人信服的研究。丹尼斯·柯尔哈恩指出，对于我们正在安置的人群，即最脆弱的“住房优先”人群，正让纳税人花费巨资。山姆的意思是，允许这些人继续无家可归正在让纳税人花费巨资。山姆一直在合作的人，他们经常被谈论为最脆弱的群体，因为他们正在应对许多额外的挑战，比如精神疾病、成瘾、
or physical disabilities. They also happened to be the people who are the most likely to stay in shelters for long periods of time, like years, and rack up visits to emergency rooms and detox centers and jails. For this particular group, studies by Dennis Cullhane and others were finding that it might actually be cheaper to do something than to do nothing. And the idea of cost savings made the housing first concept appealing to a whole new group of people. From different points of view and different value orientations. When Sam says different value orientations, he means basically Republicans. Some very notable ones ended up embracing the
或身体残疾。他们碰巧也是最有可能长期呆在收容所里的人，比如几年，并且积攒了大量去急诊室、戒毒中心和监狱的次数。对于这个特定的群体，丹尼斯·柯尔哈恩和其他人的研究发现，做点什么实际上可能比什么都不做更省钱。而节省成本的想法使得“住房优先”的概念吸引了一批全新的人。来自不同的观点和不同的价值观导向。当山姆说不同的价值观导向时，他基本上是指共和党人。一些非常知名的人最终接受了
housing first model. One of the first was George W. Bush, who helped launch several housing first style programs across the country. Fast forward a few more years and HUD, which gives a lot of money to nonprofits that work with the homeless. They're actually evaluating grant applications on how housing firstee the applications are. Sam Simberis and his colleagues and all the clients at Pathways, they had flipped the script completely. And these days most people at HUD, Ben Carson, notwithstanding, don't talk about folks being housing ready anymore. Now there's an understanding. People were always ready to be housed. Allen and Camar were ready, even though they had stumbled a little at first.
“住房优先”模式。最早的一位是乔治·W·布什，他在全国各地帮助启动了好几个“住房优先”风格的项目。快进几年，美国住房和城市发展部（HUD）向与无家可归者合作的非营利组织提供大量资金，他们实际上在根据申请的“住房优先”程度来评估拨款申请。山姆·森贝里斯和他的同事们以及“通往住房之路”的所有客户，他们彻底颠覆了剧本。如今，HUD的大多数人——抛开本·卡森不谈——不再谈论人们是否具备“住房准备度”了。现在大家达成了一种共识。人们随时准备好入住住房。艾伦和卡马尔已经准备好了，尽管他们一开始有点磕磕绊绊。
After Camar got her second place and went through rehab, she never relapsed and she never had another bout of homelessness. She recently reunited with some family, something that she says wouldn't have been possible without the stability of housing. And Allen's doing well too. He's still in housing and he still talks to Sam. Just the other day, he called him ranting and raving about a receptionist at his doctor's office who had made some kind of trivial error. And Sam says to me, Alan, what planet are you that you wake up on? He says this is everyday stuff.
在卡马尔拥有了第二处住所并完成戒毒后，她再也没有复吸，也没有再次经历无家可归。她最近和一些家人团聚了，她说如果没有住房的稳定性，这是不可能实现的。艾伦也过得很不错。他仍然住在住房里，并且仍然和山姆通话。就在前几天，他打电话来，对医生办公室里一个犯了某种微不足道错误的前接待员大发雷霆。山姆对我说，艾伦，你到底生活在哪个星球上？他说这些都是日常生活中的小事。
He says people, they make errors. And he's right about that though, yeah. The clients at Pathways taught the world that everyone was ready for a house. But what happens when there isn't enough funding for all the people in need of a home? Well, a system is created to sort out who needs it the most. A list of people ranked according to need. This was the list Tilecia Lee had ended up on, but she never got anything from it. On the next episode of According to Need,
他说人们难免会犯错。不过他这话倒没错，是的。“通往住房之路”的客户向世界证明了每个人都准备好拥有一个家了。但是，当没有足够的资金来满足所有需要家的人时，会发生什么呢？好吧，一个系统被创造出来，用以挑出最需要的人。一份根据需求排名的名单。这就是蒂莱西亚·李最终进入的名单，但她从未从中得到任何东西。在下一集的《根据需求》中，
we'll finally understand why. After the break, a preview. Thank you. Coming up on the next episode of According to Need, everyone's always referring to the list, right? Yeah, it feels a little bit like the Wizard of Oz. Like, there's someone behind this curtain that's sort of like doing some stuff that I can't figure out who it is and so... I guess my first question is like, are you the Wizard? Is this Oz? And are you like... Are you able to see where she would have ended up on that list?
我们将最终明白原因。片花过后，精彩继续。谢谢。在下一集的《根据需求》中，每个人总是提到那个名单，对吧？对，感觉有点像《绿野仙踪》。就像，幕后似乎有个人在做一些我弄不清是谁的事，所以……我想我的第一个问题是，你是那个巫师吗？这是奥兹国吗？而你是……你能查到她在那份名单上最终会排到哪里吗？
No. The list. I mean, I, that, today I even saw someone, hey, I don't know how they prioritize the list. I don't know how they're pulling people from the list. When you're looking at that list all day every day, you kind of, you become really familiar with where people are, what they rank, and it's just like mesmerizing in a sense. Everybody has their own opinion about who should be prioritized, who shouldn't.
不能。这个名单。我是说，我，今天我甚至看到有人，嘿，我不知道他们是如何对名单进行优先级排序的。我不知道他们是如何从名单中挑选人员的。当你整天都在看着那份名单时，你会对人们在哪里、他们的排名变得非常熟悉，某种程度上这让人着迷。每个人对谁应该被优先考虑、谁不应该有自己的看法。
And then you hear a lot of conversation about who's deserving, who's not deserving. So that's where you hear about the list. And the list is long right now. Because there's so much structural racism, it is much easier to become homeless if you're black. We are still talking about homelessness, like it's about the people on the street today. It's unbelievable to me. The mysterious list, how it works, and where Tilecia ended up on it. All of that is coming up on According to Need. This chapter of According to Need was produced by me, Katie Mingle, with associate producer
然后你会听到很多关于谁配得上、谁不配得上的讨论。这就是你听到关于名单的讨论的地方。现在名单很长。因为存在如此多的结构性种族主义，如果你是黑人，就更容易变得无家可归。我们仍在谈论无家可归，就好像它只是关于今天街上的人一样。这对我来说简直难以置信。神秘的名单、它是如何运作的，以及蒂莱西亚在其中的最终排名。所有这些都将在《根据需求》中揭晓。本集的《根据需求》由我——凯蒂·明格尔制作，副制作人是
Abby Madan and managing editor Whitney Henry Lester. Roman Mars was the executive producer, invaluable editing from Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, and Roman Mars. Jacob Winnick was our sound engineer, fat checking by Amy Gaines, beautiful music by the beautiful Sean Raell, branding and design by muchmore.io. Kurt Colstead was our digital director, additional support from Sofia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh, and Chris Baroube.
艾比·马丹，执行主编是惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特。罗曼·马尔斯是执行制片人，莉萨·波洛克、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰尼·霍尔、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、乔·罗森伯格和罗曼·马尔斯提供了宝贵的编辑支持。雅各布·温尼克担任我们的音响工程师，艾米·盖恩斯负责事实核查，动听的音乐由优秀的肖恩·拉尔创作，品牌和设计由muchmore.io提供。库尔特·科尔斯特德担任数字总监，索菲亚·克拉茨克、维维安·李和克里斯·巴鲁贝提供了额外支持。
Special thanks to Philip Mangano, Hillary Melton, and all the people who spoke to me for this series, as well as Marie Sol Medina-Kedena, Johanna Zorn, and Chelsea Miller. According to Need is a project of 99% invisible, which is a founding proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a network of independent listener-supported, artist-owned podcasts. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别感谢菲利普·曼加诺、希拉里·梅尔顿，以及所有为本系列节目接受我采访的人，还有玛丽·索尔·梅迪纳-凯德娜、约翰娜·佐恩和切尔西·米勒。《根据需求》是 99% Invisible 的一个项目，该节目是来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia 的骄傲创始成员，这是一个由独立听众支持、艺术家拥有的播客网络。来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。